we've heard really stupid arguments from
climate science deniers on fox news
before that's nothing new we've heard oh
it's cold and winter in North Dakota
clearly there's no climate change we've
heard Oh plants breathe carbon dioxide
so more of it must be good we've heard
Oh a senator threw a snowball in the
Senate in Windsor climate change clearly
is fake but they are now starting to
actually get angry and frustrated on Fox
News that all these stupid liberals
actually believe climate change is a
problem or better said accept the
science on the issue of climate change
check out this totally unintelligible
and quite frankly moronic rant from Pete
hagseth on Fox News the biggest national
security threat according to Bernie
Sanders is climate change the left says
it all the time
this is what they believe it is their
religion they want to fight the weather
the rest of us want to deal with real
threats that want to take away our
freedoms and and then think about four
years ago
what was that 2015 Isis was still you
know this was during Obama's term Isis
was still a huge problem the Caliphate
was there President Trump
ran on destroying Isis which he did to
their physical Caliphate now there's
remnants that we need to be concerned
about today that's taking on a real
threat directly whether it's hot or cold
the enemy is here as far as liberals are
concerned and it's all about control for
them that's why climate change is the
perfect enemy they get to control your
life to deal with it no matter what's
happening can you imagine being so out
of touch with reality that when you see
the left wanting to deal with climate
change a crisis today you think it's
about liberals wanting to control the
lives of people like can you imagine a
dumber and less informed take on this
issue other than maybe climate change is
a hoax created by China again the
weather versus climate trope surfaces
again this couldn't be more clear they
are frustrated that the left understands
and believes and more importantly
accepts science they are mad that the
left isn't falling for their propaganda
the way that many of their own viewers
have fallen for it they actually talk
about belief in climate change as if
it's like belief in God
you either have faith in it or you don't
but there's no knowable objective
reality and unfortunately for many Fox
News viewers maybe God is more real than
climate change in terms of how they view
this concept of belief and faith in
which is genuinely scary and maybe a
conversation for a different day but I
actually think that the whole concept of
belief is a misnomer you can accept or
not accept the science but belief and
faith is actually irrelevant to the
reality we shouldn't let them use this
language around these issues because it
blurs the lines between belief and God
and belief in science science as a
process you can accept it or not you can
understand it or not but it simply is it
is not pseudo religious in the way that
Peaks Pete hagseth is talking about Fox
is mad that people accept empirical
evidence over Fox's anti science
propaganda that's fundamentally what
this is about
and listen it's not just Bernie saying
climate change as a national security
threat the Pentagon agrees the military
gets it we've talked about their
assessments when the Pentagon says we
see this as such a serious issue that
we're gonna lay out a plan to fight
climate change for national security
reasons it's real
they are the extremists on Fox News when
you look at acceptance of climate change
around the world American right-wingers
aren't just out of place in the United
States or out of touch in the United
States they're out of place around the
world even right-wing parties in most
other countries accept climate change
and human effect on climate change
American conservatives are truly the
bizarre crazy outliers who simply won't
and yes Bernie's right climate change is
a national security threat but the anti
science right-wingers are also a
security threat and we're fighting them
at the same time let me know your
thoughts I'm on Twitter at D Pakman the
show is on twitter at david pakman show
and I hope that you will follow me on
Twitch at twitch TV slash David Pakman
where you can use your Amazon Prime
subscription to sign up to my channel
with twitch Prime it costs you nothing
but it counts as a paid subscription for
us and I hope you'll do that
everyone knows the risks of drunk
driving you could get in a crash people
could get hurt people could get killed
but here's some surprising statistics
almost 29 people in the US die every day
in alcohol impaired vehicle crashes that
means one person every 50 minutes so
even though drunk driving fatalities
have fallen by a third in the last three
decades drunk driving crashes still
claim more than 10,000 lives each year
many people are unaware that driving
while high is also dangerous in 2015 42%
of drivers killed in crashes tested
positive for drugs so it is not harmless
and from 2007 to 2015
marijuana use among drivers killed in
crashes doubled the truth is that
driving while high or drunk is deadly so
stop kidding yourself if you are
impaired from alcohol or drugs don't get
behind the wheel if you feel different
you drive different drive high get a DUI
drive sober or get pulled over